欢迎来好，欢迎收听新一期的翻来帐头，我是老范。
我是雪梨
咱们今天这一期呢，要跟大家聊一聊日本的便利店。
我现在回国吧，反正最不习惯的就是国内没有像日本这样满大街的便利店。
其实也不是说没有吧，就是有虽然是有，但是跟日本这边可能还是不一样的。
我就感觉好像国内一提到便利店，或者说一提到全家也好，711也好，还是罗森也好。
好像就没有这么接地气，就感觉你去那买东西好像价格总会贵一些。
但是吧，虽然说店还是那个店，但是到了日本就完全就是另一回事了。
所以呢，咱们今天就来聊一聊，这个日本的便利店，它到底有多便利。
像平时咱们便利店不就是买点吃的喝的，像什么饭团啊，便当啊，咖啡啊，这些都还正常。
甚至吧我会觉得说国内的便利店可能要比日本的要好吃。
对，因为国内的便利店除了像包子啊，关东煮啊，这种咱们在日本都快吃兔的东西以外。
它还有卖喝饭的
这个就是中国特色的便利店的品类了。
而且我还发现一个挺离谱的，就是国内的关东煮好像一年四季都有卖的。
但是日本这边好像就只有快到冬天的时候才有。
对，日本这边要是看见关东煮了，那就是说明冬天快来了。
然后吧，虽然他们都是便利店啊，但是悄悄全家和罗森我觉得他们还是有很大区别的。
我个人来讲的话，我是最选择。
我也喜欢七一一
我还没说完呢？
你不用说，我也喜欢七一一。
我最喜欢七一一，我是最不喜欢罗森的。
我也是
就是你说不清楚到底为什么不喜欢，但就是莫名其妙的不太想去。
对，就感觉对罗森提不起来好感，但是你说具体因为什么？
不知道
但至少喜欢七一一是有理有据的。
全家的话呢，原本我是最喜欢他们家的炸鸡。
但是最近呢，我们为了策划这些节目，我们去这三家，每一家都买了他们自己的炸鸡，然后横向对比了一下。
我觉得七一一的最好吃。
我也是
就是，怎么说，没有对比就没有伤害。
然后吃完之后，我就觉得七一一在我心里已经是无可争议的第一了。
其实咱们刚来的时候，那一阵，你要说炸鸡的话，没有什么可犹豫的，就是全家最好吃。
但是好像七一一经过这几年的进化。
就越来越争气
它好像赶上来了
对，不管是味道呀，还是价格呀？
虽然现在已经涨了不少了，但是在这个三家里面，它还是比较有竞争力的。
而且它这个好像刚做了没有几年。
对，七一一的这个拿拿鸡鸡好像才出了七八年嘛？
就它属于一个后来者。
对，后来者居上
而且我觉得他们家的东西，虽然，怎么说，就是各家的这个素食啊，都差不多。
就是便当啊，饭团啊，什么的。
大差不差吧，但是他们家的味道我是最喜欢的。
我是觉得七一一的这个素食的伯多统骨拉面。
或比有一些小店的更好吃。
但是仅限于七一一四家厨的这些便当。
对，而且我觉得还有一个是无可争议的第一，就是咱们俩都认同的。
就是他们家的甜品。
对，这个也不是咱俩都认同了。
是公认的
真的吗？
对，七一一的甜品是公认的。
因为是啥呢，七一一家是唯一一个有自己工厂的。
啊，就是它这个出品是很稳定的。
对，其他两个虽然说都是自营的东西，但是他们是和第三方合作的。
就说白就是贴盘的。
但是七一一是有自己的食品工厂，然后呢，他们对味道或者对品质有一个把控。
那怪不得他们这个甜品可以做得非常的顺利人心啊？
对，而且他们家的甜品你没发现，他们家甜品是更新最快的。
对，经常会在他们家买到一些什么限定啊，或者说一些新的一些产品。
对
就比如咱们俩前两天买那个。
曲奇佳心的雪梅娘，哎，特别好吃。
还有那个薄荷巧克力的泡芙。
我是特别喜欢那个。
然后他们家还有那种桃子味和梨味的冰棍。
他们家水果冰棍我觉得做的特别浓郁也特别好吃。
对，他家的冰棍会根据当季的水果出一些。
限定口味的
就比如说现在是9月份，大概日本这边梨就下来。
对
所以他会出净水梨的冰棍。
然后呢，到了冬天的时候，他就会出草莓味的。
然后他这些东西还真是那种真材实料的。
他不是那种香精味的。
对，就是你一吃就觉得他好像是把整个梨融在里边这种味道。
对对对
你想特别深的就是桃子的。
对对对，那个桃子的非常有特色。
他可以把桃子的清甜表现出来。
而且不是那种香精的味道。
对，他不是那种香精的甲甜。
也不是那种甲桃子味。
他是那种桃子的清香味。
而且你说冰棍吧？
但是又没有那么扎嘴。
而且很润
关键是他的价格不贵的。
才100多还是200多。
100多
他跟他跟其他的冰棍的价格几乎是一样。
然后还有一个将要特色。
就是他们还有一个用冷冻的水果。
现打的奶昔
就是你可以去他的冰柜里面拿一个冷冻水果的冰杯。
然后你自己打
这个也是别家没有的东西。
虽然我个人可能觉得有点喝不惯吧？
但是网上对这个的评价还挺高的。
我觉得如果有朋友要来日本玩的话。
大家可以尝试一下这个水果奶昔。
七一一给咱赞助了这期。
开始夸呀，这一顿夸呀？
你不得不说他确实是有他领先的原因的。
是
但是我下面要说的这个。
就是有点想吐槽桥要的一个店。
他们家的咖啡我真的觉得特别好喝。
就是很浓
但是现在这个咖啡它不仅量变少了。
而且价格还分贝了。
我买的AirHow的咖啡之前行也就100多块钱。
现在都变成300多日元了。
而且就只有大半杯。
好像只能装三分之二吧？
就根本装不满
你就感觉AirU赛子的那个量。
装到M赛子的那个杯里面刚刚好。
然后星巴克的那个美式。
好像一杯也就才400多块钱。
对
就是它按照赛子来说的话。
七一一的AirU赛子就是跟星巴克的那个小杯。
不对
星巴克没有小杯
人是中杯大杯超大杯。
罗老师别这样
到底是哪个杯
跟星巴克的中杯差不多大。
反正就是现在好像没有特别有性价比了。
于是以至于现在我都开始想要不要转占全家或者星巴克去买咖啡盒。
星巴克吧？
星巴克也不贵
在日本星巴克感觉就是一个普通的咖啡馆一样。
对
但是有一个问题
星巴克不像便利店一样。
到处都有
对
这个确实
而且它的速度要比便利店慢。
所以如果要通勤上班的话。
我觉得还是会首选七一一或者是全家。
然后还有一个我特别想给大家说的就是。
每一家便利店其实都会有自己的APP。
这个到了你的领域了。
可以了
这是我很擅长的东西了。
他们会不定期的在这个APP里面发各种优惠券。
什么买衣送衣
什么饮料的各种免费的兑换券。
然后你买东西的小片有时候。
偶尔也会印一些优惠券。
但是那个好像需要买一定额度。
或者说你买了固定的某一个商品。
它会在小片下面印出来一个优惠券。
所以咱们听众朋友们。
如果大家有生活在日本的。
或者说有这个APP的。
可以下一个
然后不定期的刷一刷。
没准你什么时候
就可以耗的一些资本主义羊毛。
但是其实日本便利店厉害的地方不光在于吃。
日本便利店之所以它能被称为便利店文化。
是因为它真正厉害的是能干好多奇迹怪怪的事。
对
要不然的话就叫小卖部了。
那就叫小卖部文化。
大家可能知道比较多的就是。
日本的店链可以打印取钱。
它有厕所可以用
交什么水电 没汽费。
其实这些东西都已经不算新鲜的。
就现在这个信息发达的社会。
这些东西几乎可以已经说是人尽皆知了。
对
因为网上现在有很多的攻略和帖子。
大家都已经知道了。
对
但是即使是说这些人尽皆知的功能。
其实这么多年来也会有一些变化。
就比如说打印这个东西。
我刚来的时候其实各家还没有那种APP。
所以我最开始来留学的时候。
区别那店打印什么材料的时候都必须得带一个U盘。
要不就是带一个数据线。
查到打印机上
然后把文件传到打印机里。
这么古老
对
然后出了APP
就各家都出了
然后那个时候
虽然说不用数据线了。
也不用U盘了
但是你需要什么？
你需要手动的去连。
连完了以后
它匹配到了以后
再把文件传到APP里。
然后再供邮给机器。
然后这会有一个问题。
就是它的连接不是这么的稳定。
有的时候你会搜不到信号。
对
尤其是全家的APP特别有这个问题。
然后到了现在
APP还是那个APP。
但是已经不需要你自己连接了。
你就从手机APP里面。
把你想打印的文件学好。
然后它就会自动生成一个二维码。
你到了那个便利店。
你只需要跟那个机器一扫。
它就会自动连接
然后把文件传上去。
然后你一点打印
投完钱就可以了
然后除了打印文件以外。
还有一个就是什么？
日本前些年不是开始推那个埋难吧？
就是跟那个国内身份证一样的东西。
对
就是当时日本政府为了推了一个倒霉玩意。
可耗了不少钱
那是
那是刚开始推
日本发现
没有人办
对
然后它就开始给大家发钱。
当时我记得是只要办了这个。
好像就给3万的
3万吗？
还是2万
我记得好像是2万。
2万
咱俩一共死
对
就是你只要把这个埋难吧这个东西。
关联到配配
就类似于珠宝这么一个支付的。
一个APP上面的话。
你就能拿到2万日元的。
point的反点。
这2万point其实就是钱。
可以当钱华
但是虽然说政府推了这么多年。
但是现在好像埋难吧的补纪率还是不高。
就好多人就不愿意办。
对
毕竟日本是一个非常注重。
个人隐私的一个国家。
如果你办了这个东西的话。
你很多的隐私都会被政府指导。
所以日本人不希望这种情况发生。
对
这个埋难吧其实是把你的税务。
年金保险
所有的信息好像都统合到一块了。
对
它会关联到一张卡。
就是跟咱们身份证的功能是一样的了。
而且今年的12月份开始。
好像你没有这个埋难吧的话。
确实不可以去看病了。
是因为现在保险证停发了。
所以你看病的话
后面只能用埋难吧？
所以就可能变成不得不办的一张卡。
我估计新来的朋友们。
应该是必须得办了。
对
那肯定是得办了
但是如果在这边的。
以前的保险证还能继续能用。
嗯
但虽然这个东西普及率这么低。
但是就因为这个埋难吧？
便利店的打印机又一次得到了升级。
最开始的时候
你要想打印一个著名票啥的。
得去试一试开
但是现在呢？
你只需要在便利店的打印机。
诶
刷一下这个埋难吧？
就可以直接打印了。
好
特别方便
对
我觉得这个功能对我来说非常有用。
因为以前我要开著名票的时候。
必须在周一到周五的时候去试一试。
才可以开得出来
我周一到周五的时候又不是。
一直有时间去
所以现在就变成了。
周六日或者是节假日。
只要我想去
我就可以去便利店开出这个著名票。
就很方便
我觉得咱们现在用著名票的机会还是少。
但是对于留字这个东西很关键。
对
就是留学生现在
申请什么学校呀？
考试呀？
出院呀？
就经常会需要提交这个著名票。
对
所以如果你有这个埋难吧的话。
你就不需要再特意跑一趟试一试了。
对
随时就能打印出来。
除了这个打印机以外呢？
然后就是缴费了
我觉得这个功能可能是对刚来的留的。
最有好的功能
因为现在国内的有些信用卡。
其实在国外是不认的。
上次我那个学生
哦
他想缴费
但是就不出来
对
就是但是日本这边的银行系统是不认他那张卡的。
所以以至于在脚类。
随于什么考试费呀？
或者演唱会的门票钱啊？
很多时候都是要去银行去转账的。
但是在日本
你在那个支付页面的时候。
就可以选择在便利店交。
一个是啥呢？
他会在那个支付页面上。
你选完在便利店交呢？
他就会称称一个二维码。
你把这个截图拿着这个图到便利店的收益台。
你给店员一扫
哎
就可以交了
还有一个
是你选完这个便利店缴费。
他会给你出来一串号。
你到这个便利店
有一个专门用来发行这个支付条码的机器上。
把这个号收进去
然后打印出来一张纸。
你拿着这个纸去银台缴。
这也是日本特色牢局的。
这个机器就是日本特色。
是
其他地方都找不到这种机器。
对
这种脱了裤子放屁的胡亂招也就日本干得出来。
我就我已经点了一遍了。
你还得让我再扫一遍。
但现在有了配备之后。
很多东西确实方便了很多。
就比如说像是
脚水点煤
最早我来的时候没有配备的时候。
好像大家都是每个月拿这个单子去便利店去交钱。
对
最开始的时候刚来。
其实办银行账户都不方便。
好多地位不给办的。
所以没有办法弄那个自动缴费。
就只能让他每个月挤单子。
对
但是现在至少咱们来说的话。
已经很久不去便利店缴这种费用了。
对
除非是他那个码用配备扫不了。
才会拿了这个实体的单子再去便利店。
配备这个软件
就是刚才说我们耗羊毛这个软件。
是软银跟日本牙虎合作开发的。
然后后来合资成了这个配备这个公司。
然后前几年这个配备跟支付宝打通了。
打通了以后现在在日本。
只要是支持配备的地方。
你拿支付宝扫出来的是一样的。
而且现在配备好像还有一个变化。
就是他跟微信也开了合作了。
现在你如果来旅游的话。
拿微信直接扫配备的二维码。
你也是可以直接付款的。
其实这样的合作加速了支付宝和微信。
在日本的一个普及。
所以后来好多人都以为配备是阿里巴巴做的。
就是支付宝做的
我一直是这么以为的。
其实不是
配备的技术支持是一家印度公司。
它跟支付宝半毛钱关系都没有。
就是说白了
抄的
就纯抄
居然是这样
对
就是纯抄
就几乎现在跟支付宝的功能是一模一样。
对 一模一样
买什么基金
股票
保险
然后里边还可以买电影票的地方。
然后配备还有自己的信用卡。
咱俩都有
对不对
然后就是这个便利店的ATM了。
现在日本便利店的ATM已经开始支持无卡取钱了。
我那天第一次看见的时候我都惊了一下。
我试过一回
真的非常方便
但是前提是
你手机得配置相应银行的APP。
且银行要支持无卡取款。
我记得我那次就特别傻。
我在那个ATM面前。
然后看见他有这个支持无卡取钱的操作。
我就试着试了一下。
结果发现用不了
那是因为你那个银行不支持。
对
我是单纯地以为只要没有卡。
它就可以怎么怎么就可以操作。
那不污迪了吗？
我没有卡
我想去
跟抢钱一样
对
那不存抢吗？
那就是
我用的是邮政银行的账户。
然后邮政银行的这个APP里面。
会有一个无卡取款的一个功能。
然后你打开这个功能以后。
去扫一下ATM上面这个二维码。
然后认证一下就可以取了。
其实过程非常简单。
但是你在此之前
可能得设置一下你这个手机APP。
它会有些认证
那么说了这些比较普通的功能。
以及它们的变化以后。
接下来我们就给大家介绍几个小众。
但是特别神奇的功能。
就比如说
日本的便利店是可以当做快递的收发点的。
不知道的听众朋友们。
你们现在在评论区里面抠个1。
我抠1
就是你在亚马逊或者乐天下单的时候。
你要是不方便
不在家
你就可以直接选你家附近的便利店。
到店取货
然后计快递也是
你就直接拿着东西。
到那个便利店的店头。
你跟他说我要把这个器到哪儿。
然后他就会给你一张快递单。
你贴完了以后
他给你称重 贴好。
就跟正常计快递一样。
就可以寄走了
然后他们是和黑猫合作的。
你说的这个收快递的这个。
我以前确实知道的。
但是计快递这个我确实是现在才知道。
神奇吧？
神奇
然后还有一个
就是便利店除了住民票以外。
现在还可以打印户籍藤本。
户籍藤本是什么概念的。
就是你在便利店可以打印你的货本。
作为一个外国人
你是要有住民票的。
但是作为一个日本人。
你去干什么东西是需要交户籍藤本的。
尤其是买房
所以这个活现在便利店也可以干。
对
甚至便利店还可以带收税。
它不就是接到办事处。
什么活它都能干
对
就这么说吧？
便利店就是政府24小时的办事窗口。
你除了补证件或者说是。
搬家的时候涉及到签入签出。
这种必须要去政府窗口登记以外。
基本上其他的业务都能在便利店搬了。
确实
而且我还想到一个。
就是咱们之前买那个拉机处理券。
那个东西也是在便利店可以买。
对
而且还有带我爸去钓鱼的时候。
有一个钓鱼券也是在便利店买了。
还有交罚单
对
也能在便利店交
太心痛了
而且挺贵的
日本这个罚单真的挺贵的。
伪账一次是1万5。
超速20%以内是1万8。
超速20%以上是10万。
然后
现在咱们说的这些神奇的功能。
是每家便利店都可以办的。
跟品牌无关
按照试个便利店这些东西都可以干。
除了这些共通的神奇功能以外。
其实每一家还会有自己特色的功能。
对
就比如说像711。
它很多东西是跟大创做合作的。
所以说大多数的711。
都会有一个跟大创联名的一个。
大创了专门区域
然后罗森是跟无影良品合作的。
好像你这么一笔的话。
感觉全家好没有特色。
你看711有大创。
然后罗森有无影良品。
全家有啥
全家有袜子
你是说跟logo一样配色的袜子吗？
对
看起来还挺有它自己特色的。
是啊？
那你跟logo一个配色。
那肯定是特色
谁也超不来
我跟你说
挺想买的
但是至于其他的东西。
全家说真的
我还真想不起来
我想起来一个
什么？
全家是所有便利店里面。
跟哥地凡合作最紧密的。
你想去吧？
没注意过
哥地凡的冰淇淋
哥地凡的咖啡还是什么的是吧？
哥地凡的巧克力奶昔。
这个倒是
哥地凡的甜品
还有就是咱们买扎基那天看见的。
哥地凡的饮料
我还真没注意
五百块钱一瓶饮料。
吓得咱去买几个厂上。
五百块钱买一瓶饮料。
我觉得我脑袋有点大。
再哥地凡他也五百块钱。
就买一瓶巧克力
就说这儿鬼
对
还有一个
我突然想起来的我要加一个。
还有一个日本便利店特有的功能。
现在已经没了
就是一直被大家广为流传。
津津乐道的那个小黄书曲。
这个是能说的吗？
我又没说别的
就是以前
在2020年以前。
就是日本的便利店它会有一个杂志区。
然后在杂志区的最角落里面。
会有一整排
非常清凉的杂志
就这么大杂方方的就摆这个货架上了。
你不觉得它是什么不可见人的东西。
对
这位置特别明显
一点椎焰也没有
所有人都觉得这个非常自然。
你就感觉这个就是他们便利店正常的一部分。
对
就是他们文化的一部分。
然后更离谱的是啥呢？
有些便利店的这个区域离收音台特别近。
就是你排队结账的时候。
你这个眼神都不知道该往哪儿放。
你说这个就让我想到在国内的小麦布曲结账的时候。
结账柜台也会放一些。
寄生用品
那时候你眼睛也不知道该放哪儿。
然后后来因为各种争议。
尤其是很多日本的家长会抗议说。
你在这个便利店摆这么承认像的东西。
你说对于小朋友的神经健康。
可能不太好
但是政府一直没有说出台一个明确的一个要求。
说强制性你就要把它下架。
对
我记得好像是长期这个书就一直放在那。
好像就到了奥运会是不是。
奥运会前后
对
它就是借奥运会这个名头。
其实日本政府一直想清理便利店的这个黄色杂志。
这个区域
但是一直找不到一个合适的一个气口。
然后奥运会就变成了一个很好的一个契机。
对
你毕竟要实出有名。
然后整好就借奥运会这个名头。
你是不是要给我取地了吧？
所以小王叔这个区域就变成了历史了。
我记得我之前做这个地培的时候。
以前还有客人问我说。
我能不能买两本带走了。
我说第一
它现在没卖的了
第二
你要带回去
你就这就犯法了
所以来日本旅游的朋友们。
刚才许丽也说了
不能带
便利店虽然买不着。
但是很多地方都能买得着。
如果你们想买可以私信我们。
我们告诉你俩买
但是这个东西你带不回国。
不是
私信这些东西是不是。
我给你们发挥一下。
所以咱们现在再回头看。
就随着科技的一个发展。
然后社会关键的变化。
其实便利店也在不断的去做调整。
对
它好像发展得更适合。
是怎么说家庭友好吗？
你可以这么说
其实就是说
从一个什么都行的一个状态。
到一个更加规范化的一个变化。
所以这某种程度上也是说。
便利店为什么能称得上文化的原因。
就是因为它见证了社会的一个变迁。
然后除了刚才咱们说的这些。
特别神奇的功能
特别方便的功能以外。
当然日本的便利店。
也不是什么都方便。
也有很多不方便的地方。
便利店不便利
对
首当其冲
我就必须要吐槽
就是东京都内的便利店。
好多都没有厕所
就这个倒霉事儿就让我特别大恼火。
是
你是一个没有厕所不行的人。
对
就是听证泡门里面。
我不知道你们有没有人。
做过胆囊摘除手术。
就是人如果没有了胆囊。
就特别容易复泄
因为你的胆质分泌完了以后。
没有地存
就只能顺着长道排出来。
也就是说
你会经常的复泄
尤其是刚吃完东西以后。
或者吃了一些油大的东西以后。
那么我
你就是武胆英雄
那么我就是其中一个。
便利店作为一个临时救济站。
最基本的功能就是厕所。
结果你在东京
经常推开门
问一句有厕所吗？
对
你就特别客气地决定。
跟你说
不好意思
没有
我就看着那个门上贴了一个厕所的标。
然后上面贴了一张纸。
说客人不允许使用。
只能电源使用
对呀？
你电源再不能不憋死了吧？
然后我就只能去找麦当劳或商场。
你也不好跟人说
那不就有吗？
然后那一刻
我就有一种瞬间穿越挥国的感觉。
就在街上满世界找厕所的那种无力感。
我在国内也是
所以这个时候也好像也只能找麦当劳。
到商场吗？
有一次我在都内特别着急想去厕所。
我连跑了三家便利店全都没有厕所。
而且这个事不光是我吐槽。
日本人在网上也吐槽。
就东京都内便利店没厕所这个事。
甚至还有网友给这种便利店起了一个名字叫不便店。
这个名字很好啊？
非常能够生动形象的体现出它这个缺点。
对吧？
没有厕所的便利店你就别叫便利店了。
下回
然后就有网友跳出来解释了。
说东京都内的便利店没有厕所。
或者说有厕所不给顾客用。
其实是有原因的
第一个就是什么？
日本东京地价太贵了。
所以便利店它的单店的面积就很小。
相对于周边的便利店来说。
所以好多便利店的厕所就直接拿来当仓库用了。
还有一个就是管理麻烦。
厕所要打扫
还要保持干净
而且日本人对厕所要求还是挺高的。
比如说万一有人进去带太久了。
或者说是这个卫生没搞好。
其实会影响其他客人对这个便利店的印象。
这个我能理解
对吧？
咱们两个有时候都吐槽。
这便利店厕所好干净。
或者这便利店厕所好脏。
就那种感觉
对
他会觉得你觉得这个便利店可能管理得不好。
服务不好
有这种印象
再一个就是啥
它要防止烂用
因为东京的人量太大了。
如果说人人都把便利店当公共厕所用的话。
其实店员根本就管不过来。
尤其是在车站附近的便利店。
人一多就会容易出现各种的状况。
日本的这些小流氓该溜的也特别多。
我们一个比一个神经病。
但是怎么说呢？
就是这些原因我表示理解。
但我还是觉得它没有厕所。
我不能接受
对
对于顾客来说
我不管你理由是什么？
但是你的结果就是没有。
你叫便利店
反而这些最便利的功能你不提供了。
然后就是日本的便利店的价格相对来说会贵一些。
对
那是肯定的
因为它有一些什么运营成本。
所以一般超市99块钱的一些水。
便利店一般都卖150以上。
所以如果你天天在便利店吃喝的话。
那你的生活成本要比在超市高了很多。
其实像我们准备剧节目的时候。
然后我们去各个便利店买炸鸡。
然后就随便买了点零食。
大概就要花到3000多日元左右。
一块炸鸡的话大概是200多300。
然后一个面包的话大概是100多200。
然后饮料的平均价格在100多到300多不等。
就水了100多
对
反正就是你从一家便利店出来。
至少得买大概1000多块钱。
你去这么几趟
反正我们花了35000是有的吧？
差不多
还有一个我想吐槽。
就是它经常会有一些联名或者说限定款。
我一瓶也买不着
上回有一个是共茶嘛？
就是共茶
它刚出的时候往上是铺天盖地的宣传。
中国人都抢疯了
就是因为这么宣传。
基本上所有的店全都没货。
当时都内的便利店找不到全是空的。
结果我们是在我们家这边的便利店。
就没啥中国人的地方。
没人买
随便买
货特别起
但你别说它那个确实很好喝。
就是共茶出的一个芒果乌龙茶。
它都现在好像还有。
但就是在东京都或者中国人多的地方。
可能这种限定的不会太好抢。
然后就是你赶上人多的时候。
其实整个体验还是不太好的。
因为日本的便利店承担的业务太多了。
确实
就像咱们俩刚刚介绍的那些。
就光听听就让人觉得很头大了。
对
就是店员你要负责好多好多好多事。
然后就导致啥呢？
人一多了以后
你排队就特别慢
对
然后说你想买瓶水。
前面那个大瓶在鸡块地。
让你就要等
它一般会有两个收音台。
有一个如果处理一个复杂业务的话。
另一个会开开
你嫁不够再来一个交费。
没交明白呢？
我就是有遇到过这样的。
而且我遇到的那个。
那个结账的店员还是东南亚的人。
他对于整个业务还没有完全熟悉。
而这个时候碰巧他的店长还不在。
那就是灾难
那对于那个便利店或者对于。
在便利店那些人来说就是个灾难。
所以这个时候就导致你的体验有点不好。
其实咱们刚才说了这么多。
便利店的方便也好。
不方便也好
其实我一直都觉得。
日本的便利店跟国内的便利店。
虽然都挂着
翘摇也好
全家也好
罗森也好
都挂着一样的牌
但是吧？
他们完全就不是一个东西。
你在国内像翘摇这种店吧？
你就感觉有点不接地气。
就是那种
你进去之前
你心里就已经有数了。
Z里面的东西要比我们家小卖部的东西贵。
嗯
然后你已经接受了那个价格了。
对
就虽然说店还是那个店。
你货价摆的东西其实跟日本也大差不差。
但是那种氛围就是不一样的。
我觉得国内便利店。
其实更多的是一个补充。
就是说你要说临时想买水或者买包烟。
或者随手买点零食啥的你就进去。
但是说真的要是说日常来用的话。
还是说楼下的小卖部。
或者说市场来得更方便一点。
所以其实在国内便利店不是必须的。
它更多是一个锦上天花的一个功能。
但是在日本
其实便利店就完全不一样了。
我觉得便利店至于日本。
就有点像小卖部至于国内。
就是那种不管你什么时候去。
它都在那儿
你知道这有一个
你心里就会觉得踏实。
对
你说到这个我想起来一个事儿。
就是我大学的时候有一个日语外教。
当年他从明古屋到了北京。
去当外教之后
他最想念的
他说捐不是寿司
而是日本的便利店。
为什么想念呢？
他作为外教经常会给我们要印卷子。
所以有一次他就找了一个罗森。
就进去了就想找一个打印店。
结果发现他找了几个便利店。
都没有找到有打印机。
然后他说在日本的便利店。
连打印机都有
根本不需要去其他店打印。
可是那时候在国内。
就咱们上学那时候要打印一个东西。
都得去那种挂着红色招牌的图文打印店。
就是一进门有十几台电脑。
还需要先提前把文件考到那个U盘上。
再去打印
黑白的一毛彩色的两毛就这样。
他说他当时就特别不能理解。
然后当然心想
我说这东西真有这么方便吗？
因为我也不知道这个日本。
带打印机的便利店是什么样子的。
我就根本没法想象。
然后结果来了之后发现。
确实是不一样
对
日本的便利店才真的称得上做便利店。
他才称得上是便利。
对
国内的便利店他就可以统称为小卖部。
他就只是卖东西的。
但是他还跟国内的小卖部不一样。
小卖部你听这个词的觉得特别的亲切。
我也想到就是那种。
我上学的时候
卖五毛一块的小零食的那样。
对
就老板就坐在那
然后你跟他说两句话。
然后熟了以后
你要是没带钱还能收账。
特有人情味
对
但是日本的便利店可能没有这样的人情味。
但是你走进去以后就会觉得安稳。
还真的是这样
对吧？
就是有点像啥呢？
就是国内的小卖部。
给你更多的是一种人情味。
但是日本的便利店给你的是一种安全感。
你是真的可以得到便利的那种。
然后我们再说回吃的。
国内的便利店吃的其实是比日本好的。
全家711在国内经常有这种新品。
而且有现做的什么三明治 热饭菜之类。
其实花样要比日本多的。
对 日本这边的就那几样。
咖喱 鸡块 拉面什么的就这样。
对
但是问题就在这了。
为什么日本人还听进去。
其实是因为对他们来说。
便利店不是吃饭的首选。
而是兜底
就算你哪天不想做饭。
不想去餐厅
便利店也随时能给你一个不会出错的一个选择。
就是它不是最好吃的。
但是你去那一定没错。
跟中华料理在他们心里的地位是一样的。
对
而且还有一个特别大的差别。
就是在国内你进不进便利店。
完全取决于你有没有一个需求。
一年到头不去都行。
你想去吧？
对 但是现在就算你不出门。
你也可以在家完成这个需求。
因为现在国内的网购什么都已经很方便了。
所以人们不一定非得去便利店。
对
甚至说你去家里附近的什么煎酒店。
小麦不如你更舒服。
但是在日本 其实便利店就是日常。
你每天上下班的时候。
出门溜地一圈 顺手就进去一趟。
买个水上个厕所 交个费。
对吧？
买个扎机 买个冰激凌。
对
为啥咱俩减不了费呢？
对日本的便利店它是你生活的一部分。
它不是一种选择
而是一种安全感
然后我有一次回国。
走在街上的时候突然发现。
没有满达街的便利店。
我就会有一种
说不上来的感觉
就是那种心里有点不安。
不是说国内没有便利店。
而是说他们的密度不一样。
就在日本便利店多少什么地步呢？
从我们家到车站大概有。
3公里左右的一个距离。
然后这一条路上
我们大概能遇到6个便利店左右。
除了传统的玉三家。
711罗森和全家以外。
还有勇望旗下的mini stop。
对
还有一个叫做daily的一个便利店。
然后车站里面还有一个叫new days。
但是在国内
就是你走好几条街可能都没有。
甚至你要到某一个商场。
或者说某一个地铁站的里面才有。
所以才说
我觉得便利店不光是一个店。
它更是一个社会的一个缩影。
就是国内的便利店更接近于小卖部。
背后其实体现的是一个人情的一个社会。
老板知道你爱喝什么饮料。
或者说街里街坊还能搭个茶聊个天。
买东西的时候顺便就可以搭个两句。
但是在日本便利店就完全不一样。
它代表了一个讲规矩的一个社会。
就是你进去流程清清楚楚。
交水电有条码 计块地有单子。
连打印资料都有一个标准化的一个流程。
你该怎么做就怎么做。
没有任何问题 也不会出错。
但就是缺少了一些人情。
对 所以有些中国人在日本生活的。
不是很习惯
我觉得其实也就是因为这个。
对
因为在国内很多事都是靠人情去打通的。
对不对 走走观据都能办。
但是在日本可能一切都得按照规矩来。
你按照规矩办 事情就一定能解决。
但就因为他们照张办事这个毛病。
就使得他们缺少了一些灵活性和人情味。
但是你说这两种哪个好哪个坏不好说。
但只是说对于生活在日本的人来说。
这就是我们每天要面对的一种真实的感受。
对 而且它是我们在日本生活绕不开的一部分。
也是让我们这些外国人慢慢学会。
在这种规矩里面找自己的生活方式。
而且我还觉得
便利店对我来说
它不仅是一个买东西交费的一个地方。
就是它见证了我在日本生活的这些年。
从留学到上班
从第一次在那打个简历都能觉得震惊。
到现在已经习惯了顺手去便利店交费啥的。
它更像一路陪着我成长的一个背景版一样的存在。
我觉得能听到这里的朋友们。
如果你们还没订阅我们。
希望你能给我们点一个订阅。
因为在陪伴范莱张口成长的同时。
也希望我们能成为你们生活中的一个好伙伴。
就像便利店在日本陪伴着。
每一位默默打拼的中国人一样。
所以你们生活中有开心的。
不开心的困惑或的生气的事。
也都可以在评论区或者私信告诉我们。
你们在小宇宙也好。
小红书也好
甚至微信公众号都可以找到我们。
听完这一题
你们对于日本便利店好奇的。
吐槽的喜欢的点又是什么呢？
也希望你们能在评论区里告诉我们。
好不好
那以上就是本期节目的全部内容了。
我是老范
我是雪梨
我们下期再见
拜拜